[Music]
[Applause]
I'm gonna burn this place to the ground
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my new marvel Falcon in
Winter Soldier video for the viral
teaser they they just released they also
had a Disney investor meeting where they
aired a full-blown new Falcon and Winter
Soldier trailer with all new footage
I'll explain that too there's a whole
bunch of Easter eggs so if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the Marvel videos there's a bunch of
really big stuff coming up so we'll just
bring this down top-five style starting
with number 5 happy birthday Winter
Soldier so obviously this is them having
a little bit of fun teasing the series
but in this clip Winter Soldier is
celebrating his 107 Thursday I saw a lot
of you confused about the timeline on
this why is he hundred and seven years
old instead of some other age what is
the date on this filter raid March 10th
2020 instead of 2023 I think that's
mostly just a joke just because the
person who was recording this didn't
have a way to change the actual date you
have to remember the Avengers end game
ended in the spring of 2023 so
technically all this is happening years
in the future Winter Soldier was born as
Bucky March 10th 1917
so the Falcon and Winter Soldier clip
that we're watching here of him getting
ready to plow through this cake is
taking place in 2024 the year after
avengers endgame which is why they're
celebrating his 107 day the clip is
taking place in a restaurant in Prague
Czech Republic because that's where they
were filming the last of their episodes
recently they're getting ready to wrap
on the series the connection you'll
remember to Spider Man far from home is
that that's where spider-man fought his
battle with Mysterio's big fire
elemental at the carnival when he got
his night monkey stealth suit the reason
why he's wearing a special glove there
is just because he wears the glove over
his special vibranium arm just so he
doesn't freak people out this is what he
looks like in his full battle costume
he's got a couple costume changes
through the series and they will be
hyping up all the special abilities that
his arm has they haven't talked about it
recently but a little while ago they
were talking about how his arm has all
these secret functions that sharee built
into it because it's vibranium
technology of course it does a lot of
really cool secret stuff so they'll be
using the Falcon and Winter Soldier
episodes to show us a lot of those cool
things but that's just one of the cool
details about the series but number four
the brand new footage that they showed
up at the Disney investor meeting starts
like an extended trailer it's Bucky
paying a visit to Baron Zemo in that
state-of-the-art prison that they locked
him up in during Captain America Civil
War Baron Zemo tries to reactivate his
Winter Soldier programming again like
the language that he got from the red
book only now it doesn't work because
Cherie in black panther deep programmed
him before Avengers infinity war the
reason why Winter Soldier says he's come
to see Baron Zemo though is because
someone has recreated the Super Soldier
Serum obviously we're probably talking
about Thunderbolt Ross here because we
know that he has a version of the Super
Soldier Serum that he used during
Incredible Hulk you're aware that we've
got an infantry weapons development
program while in ww2 they initiated a
subprogram for biotech force enhancement
super soldier yes an oversimplification
but yes and I dusted it off got him
doing serious work again both were
banners work was very early phase
he thought he was working on radiation
resistance then there's a longer version
of this trailer scene of the rally where
they're minting the new version of the
John Walker u.s. agent Captain America
they're getting ready to introduce them
you only see him off screen holding the
shield in his costume but this is the
government getting ready to announce him
publicly in this big rally then there
was a montage of a bunch of big action
scenes with Baron Zemo finding in his
comic book costume with the iconic
purple mask then they follow up with a
different scene of Winter Soldier
meeting Falcon discussing that they're
not really Bros they were just friends
of friends they knew Captain America
collectively so they're just two dudes
that used to know Captain America
obviously by the end of the series
they'll probably become fast friends but
you've probably seen a lot of the funny
clips and teasers that they posted to
social where they're trash-talking each
other there just to give you an idea for
the tone of the series when things pick
up the timeline of Falcon and Winter
Soldier is that it picks up relatively
soon after avengers endgame but also
after the events of spider-man far from
home
spider-man far from home is still like
the first thing that happens a couple
months after avengers endgame there is a
logic to the order of all
the Disney Plus Avengers series the ones
that they've announced so far so like
Falcon to Winter Soldier is the first
one to be released this summer in August
after Comic Con because all the stuff
that happens during the episodes
happened before the story in one
division Episode one picks up so a lot
of the stuff that they do during Falcon
and Winter Soldier will set the stage
for what's happening in the other Disney
Plus series because they're all meant to
be connected but they're also all
connected with the movies to of course
I'll cover all those Easter eggs and all
those connections when they start
releasing more trailers more footage in
the actual episodes number three most of
you know that Baron Zemo is the main
villain to this most of the stuff that's
happening during Falcon and Winter
Soldier is in service of establishing
the MCU Thunderbolts and that's gonna
spread into the MCU movies through
Thunderbolt Ross and Baron Zemo I know
everyone just watched the Black Widow
trailer watching him copy all of Black
Panthers and the other Avengers moves
and they're hoping the taskmaster will
join the Thunderbolts in the future but
of course as you would expect Baron Zemo
escapes prison all the craziness of
Avengers in game and the blip back sets
that off the same way that they used the
ending of Avengers endgame to explain
why Mysterio was doing his Iron Man plot
during spider-man far from home no big
surprise that they're gonna be using the
events of Avengers endgame to inform the
events of the next several big MCU
movies number two the other big part of
Falcon and Winter Soldier episodes are
addressing what happens with the shield
in Captain America's legacy as you've
all seen from that Avengers end game
ending scene cap wanted Falcon to take
it first spin Falcon and Winter Soldier
episode 1 is supposed to pick up a while
after Avengers end game with a big
attack from Baron Zemo in the same style
as his attack during Captain America
Civil War during that event it's
supposed to be revealed that Thunderbolt
Ross and the government have selected US
agent John Walker as their new Hardcore
trigger-happy version of Captain America
that they can control Falcon and Winter
Soldier obviously have history with
Baron Zemo which is where they get
involved trying to stop his global
terror plot in while that's happening
Falcon has this big arc of not wanting
to be the new Captain America doubting
himself in his they're chasing Baron
Zemo around the world they learned the
true history of the super soldier
program and meet a couple other
participants they cast Karl Lumley most
people believe that he's playing
Isiah Bradley from the comics he's the
next person that the military tried to
turn into a super soldier right after
Captain America during World War two the
version of the serum that they tested on
him wasn't quite as potent as Captain
America's Super Soldier Serum but
remember that Thunderbolt Ross seen from
Incredible Hulk where he's talking about
the history of the Super Soldier program
in the Weapon X program MCU Isiah
Bradley would just be part of that
program so as they learn about the
history of the super soldier program
Falcon slowly comes around on the idea
of wearing the mantle of Captain America
in number one the Falcon in Winter
Soldier episodes are supposed to start
releasing by late August
new episodes always release on Disney
Plus on Fridays they also just confirmed
that the Loki series would be starting
to release around this time next March
they've already confirm Loki in the time
variants Authority I've done a couple
videos about that so I'll link my Loki
trailer video in the description but
they also confirmed that they're doing
the Enchantress time travel villains
multiverse villains because that's just
who that time parents Authority always
goes after Owen Wilson is part of the
series they didn't say who he's playing
though and now they just confirmed a
Richard II grant will be playing a big
villain everyone seems to think that
he's gonna be playing MCU King the
conquer because you don't cast Richard
II Grant who plays iconic huge villains
and movies to be a throwaway villain in
all the big characters from each of the
Disney Plus series are supposed to cross
over into the movies but we'll get more
details about that soon so I'll do more
videos on the other Disney Plus series
as they release new footage and new
details
Marvel is also getting ready to confirm
Sam Raimi as the director of Doctor
Strange 2 multiverse of madness we all
know that he's going to direct the movie
but officially Marvel hasn't said
anything about it because they're deep
in pre-production they start filming
Doctor Strange 2 in May so just expect
them to start talking about Doctor
Strange 2 next month as you probably
heard Doctor Strange 2 is going to be
the most important Marvel movie next to
the Eternals for setting up the next 10
years of the MCU the reason why the
Eternals is a really big deal even
though those characters are kind of
weird and you may not have seen them
before or may not have read those Jack
Kirby comics is because the Eternals
provide the basis for x-men inside the
MCU I know you're all expecting to see
some x-men stuff happening during one
division - yes that
we'll set up mutants but remember Wan
Division is coming out after the
Eternals which is why the Eternals is
the first big thing that's going to be
setting up MCU x-men all to Easter eggs
for all that stuff when they start
releasing eternals trailers that'll
probably start in May when we get the
Black Widow movie
congratulations Griffin's see well
you're the giveaway winner from my last
big Marvel video of the movie tickets
please email me on the about page of my
channel so I can get your contact
details
everyone click here for my new Thor for
Christian Bale video and click here for
Marvel's big announcement about what's
going on with the Hulk during Marvel
phase 4 in Marvel phase 5 thank you so
much for watching everyone stay awesome
see you guys tonight
[Music]